hello lovely people i'm alan welcome to
my channel where today i'm making a very
quick video
basically i'm gonna have to try not to
edit this either because i can't use
either of my hands um because i got in
an accident
which i will not detail because uh
i was not at fault and i might get a
very big ambulance bill and we'll see if
that becomes a
thing i have to deal with but um yeah
basically can't use my hands can't play
video games right now
so there have been no videos this week
uh we did still manage to record the
podcast we're supposed to initially
record it on tuesday but then i was like
i can't there's no way i can
do this that day it was just way in too
much pain that it was like
visibly obvious whereas now i'm kind of
at a point where my knee really hurts
but generally if i'm sitting i'm okay
so i can make this we did get the
podcast on that'll be up tomorrow
but yeah really just here to tell you i
can't stream i can't type very well
uh i can't make most kinds of content
it's not
exactly how i planned to start my 2020
but uh you know things happen um my
hands are getting a little bit better
this one
still terrible this one actually doesn't
really hurt anymore
um but looks truly disgusting
i could put a picture up for you guys if
you want to see how they looked
yesterday which is like several days
after this accident on
sunday just close your eyes for the next
like five no then i have to edit it
never mind
i was gonna be like i could put the
picture up but i can't edit the video
there are things that you think would be
really simple that become not simple
when you've been in this kind of
accident like i can't pull
sheets up if i'm cold because it hurts i
have no grip strength
on my fingers so i can't like open a
water bottle
just stupid [ __ ] that
most of the time i'm fine and i just
have to sit and i can still do my job
i'm still working
um they've let me you know take it
pretty easy but i am still working but
sometimes it's just really sad i have to
you know try like as hard as i
physically can
open a water bottle and i can't here we
are but yeah mostly okay
this arm pretty messed up elbows really
soul
this one's fine i can move this quite
well but you know
that's that really i will hopefully be
back to making stuff
next week um i will let you guys know
[ __ ] it is what it is 20 21 everyone